[Music]
thankfully one of the biggest scams in
the American tax code is finally under
attack in the House version of
Republican tax reform
it's the mortgage interest deduction
which currently lets homeowners deduct
interest paid on mortgages of up to 1
million dollars for two houses
[Music]
ever since owning a home has been a
central tenet of the American Dream
since the end of World War two in the
rise of suburbia it's been a given that
deducting mortgage interest from your
taxes is as American as apple pie
the house plan would limit filers to
deducting interest on the first five
hundred thousand dollars of a mortgage
on just one house sending a blind panic
through wealthy homeowners Realtors and
the building trades all of whom are
terrified that a government subsidy is
being yanked away from them we are very
concerned with the limitation on the
mortgage interest deduction and it's
really limited into what's the real
problem with the House bill is that it
doesn't go far enough
we should scrap the mortgage interest
deduction all together and let housing
prices reflect real market values the
mortgage interest deduction is typically
justified by claiming that it lets
people especially vaguely defined
middle-class people afford homes but it
also increases the price of housing by
making it artificially cheap to borrow
money meaning homebuyers are willing to
borrow more England Canada and Australia
don't let their tax payers deduct their
mortgage interest and they all have
higher rates of homeownership than the
United States the mortgage interest
deduction disproportionately benefits
the wealthiest Americans who soak up
almost all of the seventy billion
dollars a year it costs in foregone
revenue each year the tax bill both the
House and the Senate versions both of
them leave alone for the most part the
mortgage interest deduction which is one
of the most ridiculous parts of the tax
code recent foundations director of
economic research in thini Randazzo
calculates that only 20% of tax filers
claim the mortgage interest deduction
that group by and large are part of
six-figure households in a country where
the median household income is just
fifty-seven thousand dollars
killing the mortgage interest deduction
might cause a one-time 7% drop in real
estate prices according to one estimate
with wealthy homeowners feeling most of
the pain speaking as a homeowner that
seems like a small price to pay to end a
policy that distorts the real estate
market complicates the tax code and
benefits mostly wealthier Americans all
on the false promise that it makes home
owning affordable for the middle class
the mortgage interest deduction is just
special interest pandering wrapped in a
gooey story that equates the American
dream with having a mortgage the tax
code should be designed to raise the
revenue necessary to pay for essential
services not to nudge and prod us into
spending money on something the
government decides as good for us the
house tax reform plan would be at least
a good down payment on a more
libertarian tax code
[Music]